[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down Graphics plan in secret
Invasion Episode 2 has just dropped and
it reveals a lot of key clues about
what's going on with the Scrolls
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down all the hints and also
talking about what's really going on
with their secret Invasion now this
includes heavy spoilers from the comics
so if you don't want to know then check
out now we will be covering secret
Invasion every single week as well so
make sure you stick around for videos on
the series every Wednesday but out of
the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into gravic's plan
[Music]
so before discussing exactly what's
going on we have to look at the comics
and why Earth was their target part of a
squirrel's religion prophesies that
their home would be destroyed and this
is something that exists in a lot of
myths and legends Christians for example
believe in the Book of Revelations and
the asgardians believe in Ragnarok and
so on and so forth apocalypse are built
into almost every aspect of society but
after this comes a time of rebirth and
regrowth the skrulls believe that one
day Galactus would destroy their home
and then from this point on they'd make
their home on a blue planet the thing
with Galactus came to be and it was
taken during the cree scroll War which
then made them believe in the next part
of the plan in the comics after the cree
scroll War the Illuminati went to them
and they just basically said look mate
back off suffering a humiliating defeat
at the hands of Captain Marvel and the
rest of the earthlings they were in a
bad place and the heroes just showing up
added salt into the wound they told them
they'd wipe out all the Scrolls that
they ever assaulted it again but all
this did was piss off the Emperor once
more is made you look a right knob
capturing the heroes he experimented on
them and found ways to mimic their
abilities and copy their memories too
you see one problem the Scrolls had
always run into was that the Avengers
were stronger and more powerful than
them so every time they tried to attack
Earth they were inevitably beaten
because their shape-shifting ability
simply weren't a match for weapons it
was also the fact that the humans were
getting better at sniffing them out and
under scrutiny the Scrolls simply didn't
hold up for example if a character like
Professor X read their mind he'd
instantly know the truth so they
couldn't Infiltrate The X-Men or anyone
with telepaths Wolverine and people with
heightened senses could easily sniff
them out and Spider-Man's Spider Sense
would be triggered if they got close so
squirrels though dangerous weren't that
difficult to defeat which is why they
realized they had to up the stakes and
put better things in place studying the
hero's DNA they managed to start
mimicking their powers and on top of
this they came up with a ways to get
around telepaths recreating their
memories perfectly this girls could
convince as soldiers they were actually
the people they were portraying so
they'd even pass a lie detector test if
it came to it for all intents and
purposes the Scrolls believed they were
the heroes that they were playing and
they ended up becoming sleeper cells
inserted on Earth it was only under
certain circumstances that things within
them triggered and they realized that
they were actually Scrolls sent out to
do a mission and those are some of the
key parts of the mission that we have in
place and I think a lot of them are also
being brought into Graphics plan as well
we know that the Scrolls have the
ability to copy memories and gravicles
that has something in place for the
Avengers and what happens if the
Avengers return
you don't think I thought about that now
this is something that we also discover
in the entry when guy comes across files
containing several names amongst these
are Groot a frost beast and col obsidian
as well as some extremists showing what
they're trying to do now I believe that
in the end he's attempting to make super
Scrolls which are a big part of Scrolls
in the comics the original Super scroll
mimic the Fantastic Four powers and I
don't think it's a coincidence that
there's four powers here as well firstly
we have Groot whose branches were likely
found down on wakanda and we also have a
frost beast from the end of Thor the
Dark World collabsidian's hand was cut
off during Infinity war and extremis was
last seen early in chongqi gravic
collected these because they all come
with key abilities that if mimicked will
help him create scroll super soldiers
group can create long branches extremely
fast from his arms and this is something
that we've seen gravic doing in the
trailers the frost beasts extremely
strong as is called obsidian and
extremist will allow him to quickly heal
from wounds this should be be enough to
even the feel when it comes to the
Avengers and having them out the way
will embolden the Scrolls further the
next part of the plan involves in sing
Scrolls into powerful positions where
they can influence and control the
entire world's populace in episode 2 we
see that this has come to be in that
there's Scrolls in almost every aspect
of the world the NATO leader the British
PM which I'll take over what we've got
media Moguls and much much more this
gives them power and influence and it
also happened in the comics with us
getting a big splash page where the
Scrolls replaced a ton announcing
themselves to the world over screens
across the planet we saw exactly who'd
been taken and replaced with one it was
Barack Obama Oprah Winfrey Tom Cruise
and the guy who never hits the Thumbs Up
Button the heroes had to go back and
like the video to even out the odds but
that didn't stop how deep they'd managed
to get in now graphic has that as well
and we also seen the trailers that he
attacks the presidential Convoy with
Ritz and set inside I'm guessing that
this is an attempt to potentially swap
the the president out but either way
it's probably going to lead to General
Ross in charge Marvel Marvel have
already spoiled a number of things and
we know that Ross will be president for
the next Captain America movie Nick Fury
will also be fine and on saber by the
time we get to the Marvels and I do kind
of wish we didn't know so much about the
future although this could be an attempt
to grab him so that they can put their
own president in place I actually think
that they want someone like Ross placed
upon the hot seat and that ties into the
main part of gravic's plan which we saw
playing now at the end of episode 1
unleashing a dirty bomb in Moscow this
has made Rush intentions Flair and it
has the potential to start a worldwide
war I've been working on a breakdown of
Terminator 2 and Skynet did the same
thing in that as they knew the
counter-attack would take out most the
humans being used in every aspect of
military software in the US they
launched nukes to hit the Russians which
then caused them to go and fire back now
we have Scrolls in every aspect of
society at this point so if it came down
to it I'm sure they're happy be the fire
away what I think is that written might
be a slightly less temperamental leader
and he'll probably try and sort things
out instead of sending the country to
war however if Ross is in charge he'll
likely Go full steam ahead as this is a
guy who refuses to back down he's
someone who stood up to the Hulk and
even the Avengers themselves so I doubt
he's gonna take it lying down when it
comes to Russia now this will put the
entire world on a knife edge and with
the Scrolls in key positions they could
cause more death and destruction sending
soldiers to war and destroying vast
parts of the planet means that they'd
have several things that would help to
destroy Humanity in the Wasteland of War
terrorist attacks and floods of
misinformation no one would know who to
trust and who to really turn to this is
where the Scrolls could come in and
posing as people in positions of power
they could easily sway people into
falling into line offering salvation
even if the groups in Earth this could
cause paranoid and distrust amongst the
people of Earth everyone will be so
paranoid that they'd be firing on each
other simply on the off chance so they
were standing against a scroll it's
genius when you think about it and it's
also some of the villains did in the
comics too due to the heroes becoming
aware that the Scrolls could be
programmed to be sleeper cells we also
had Heroes questioning if they were real
nowhere was this scene more in Tony
Stark who at one point was convinced he
was actually a scroll Soldier having a
complete psychological breakdown he was
easier to manipulate and it allowed the
Scrolls to sink their claws and even
further now this is something that I
think might be brought across to Nick
with them potentially persuading him
that he's a scroll too when we look at
it it shouldn't be that difficult to
pull off and and this is due to all the
things that's going on in his life he of
course married a scroll and had them
poses them before so they might not even
have to work that hard to make it seem
the case I also think they might reveal
Graphics posing as Nick's son and this
could be the person that they use to
base his whole look off Scrolls tend to
take on the form of one person and then
they stick with this forever so having
an attachment to Fury would make things
hit even harder if this is the case then
on top of what we've just mentioned you
could probably do a compelling argument
that Nick's not actually human I hope
elements like this are brought across
because it's such a cool bit in the
comics that even had me question exactly
what was going on so in conclusion we're
gonna wrap the video up but here's what
I think graphics plan is he wants to
start a war between Russia and the us
and this will take out several key
figures across the entire planet
everyone will be so wrapped up in war
they'll not even be paying attention to
what's really happening and this will
allow them to oust the leaders and put
the Scrolls in their place in Excel so
does trust and paranoia which will make
people turn on each other and this is so
that they can get the planet as their
home they'll finally be able to take it
and anyone who tries to stop them will
be met with the powers of the newly
created super Scrolls lots of things are
slotting into place but I'm pretty
confident that's what we'll get alright
let me know if you disagree or agree
with our theories now if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below as it massively helps us
out we'll give you early access to
videos every week and we also have our
merch store over at shopzeroedition.com
which sells lots of different clothing
we just launched a secret Invasion slash
Pulp Fiction inspired t-shirt so if you
want to head over there and help us out
then the links in the description now if
you want something else to watch we've
got our breakdown of episode two on
screen right now which goes over all the
Easter eggs hidden details and just our
general theories on it without the way a
huge thank you this thing through the
video I've been poor I'll see you next
time you take care peace and I was a
scroll the whole time you sucker
foreign